hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
you
[__] how are you
how's your week going oh
that's fantastic I had oh my God I'm
gonna sneeze
I mean it's one of those ones we just
gotta sit there and stare at something
with your eyes squinted you know
blinking sort of in an odd way and then
it goes away
whenever you announced oh my God I have
to sneeze you never do unless the sun is
there and you can turn around and just
stare down that demon
you know there's a new Theory out there
that you know for all these years all
these people praying to the sun god that
the Sun God is actually the devil
hiding in plain sight
you know like every time they catch a
serial killer they're always like hiding
in plain sight like what where where
where are the other ones
are they off the grid
they're all hiding in plain sight
they're in society they are amongst us
what does he come down from the [__]
mountains like Bigfoot
hey man can you uh give me a [__]
right sort of an Elvis vibe
oh this one for them on it to fall to
show sticky in the trunk and here we go
sorry
um
anyway yeah that's always great yeah I
I've read something recently that the
sun is not the Sun
it's actually Satan
right
that's what you guys know I'm full of
[__] when I go right and the World is
Flat
and uh
he's he's gonna cook us
that's what he's been trying to do all
these years so for all these years he's
been getting into these CEO's heads
and just like yeah man keep doing that
tear down that mountain
get the stuff that's in it
the results of this by the time it
happens you'll be dead don't worry about
it
that's for the Next Generation to deal
with
and now it's time to pay the tolls I
blame the people that used your products
after use that were playing the game
that you set up
um no I didn't read anything that the
sun was actually Satan
I had nothing to do with it I tell you
what is Satan
let's talk about Satan this week first
of all satanists for when I learned a
long time ago
don't believe in the devil they just
believe in you know doing what feels
good for themselves
which means not watching the children
and doing blow three times a week
um
sorry I had to hit pause
the kid was screaming and yelling in the
background you ever take a vacation and
you don't feel rested at all if that's
the case you're a dad
um
[Applause]
oh I was gonna tell you what's been dry
like
um this is style of video I think I've
talked about it before I alluded to it
you know what I mean
what do people call that uh when there's
a um
there's a little Easter eggs little
Easter eggs in movies if you catch it
you catch it if you don't you don't it's
just a little Easter egg you know
these little cool things in movies are
only for Christians
um are we the only ones that believe in
Easter
bill could you be any more all over the
map
I didn't get a lot of sleep last night
my son for whatever reason likes to get
up at two or three in the morning
and just come walking in our room and
then I got to put him to bed and then he
wants me he won't sleep in his little
boy bed he sleeps in the guest room bed
and then he wants me to get in there and
then he just [__] crawls all over me
kicking me kicking me kicking me kicking
me kicking me kicking me kicking me
kicking me kicking me for about [__]
three hours and then what's funny he's
writing is the sun goes up he [__]
passes out
and I look at him and it looks like he's
been unloading like working like UPS or
something like he just got back from his
shift like that's how hard he's sleeping
so a little sleep deprived little
deprived
not deprived deprived
um
anyway
the style of video that's been driving
me nuts
is those videos where somebody's gonna
do something and it's just a bunch of
quick edits with the sound
of what they're doing
like if they were gonna like you know
like make some scrambled eggs to be the
sound of the bowl hitting the counter
Tink
crack the egg into the bowl
[Music]
turn the stove on
Skillet clink on butter in
and you pour the thing in it oh
who the [__] finds that entertaining I
watched this guy the other day he had a
car that I liked and I wanted to see a
video of the car so what the [__] did
they do first shot close-up of the key
going into the door
then he turns it and then I then they
cut to his thumb pressing on the button
and then the door opening and then him
sitting that she shot a [__] car
Jesus [__] Christ can you imagine if
life was actually like that like sounds
were that [__] intense
or at least um
showcased
if every time I wanted some scramble who
doesn't like scrambled eggs right every
time I had scrambled eggs I had to
endure that [__] process I would I
don't know what I would do
what else could you have
you know what I'll have an apple
then all I have to do is just watch you
reach over grab it and then [__] hand
it to me no they'd wash it
is one of my favorite things how
somebody made a video like that
somebody's like oh my God that's cool
I'm gonna shoot something in the in that
style and then everybody on [__]
Instagram is like we're all gonna do it
too and you know what's great is it edit
no point will it become annoying and
unoriginal just keep doing it
oh I am [__] wired I can't wait I'm
going to the gym today oh Billy boy's
going to the gym
the testosterone's going down but the
weights are going up
yeah I'm at that age I I'm just losing
muscle mass
you know so what I got to do is what
every guy does at my age you either
accept the fact that you're mortal or
you do steroids
he's coming back
you know what's funny is I think there's
so many people on roid's and HGH a
testosterone pills
you know what's going to become extinct
is that the you know you know the little
old lady the little old man the cute
little [__] you know
just going up oh and what do you do oh
that's lovely
would you like to play some cards oh
that would be fantastic right that's all
gonna go away it's just gonna be some
[__] 80 year old guy pulling over
here you want somebody you want some of
this smoke
if I [__] see that one he didn't want
that smoke he wanted all of that smoke
the smoke was there and he partook how
many ways can you dissect that [__]
joke
let's talk about Instagram hack
here's another one why don't somebody
else graph an incident with [__] around
versus find out it's still funny
it's still funny the 490th time of
[__] video does that
haven't said that
I was actually talking to Nia the other
night how unbelievably [__] funny it
seems the average person is
um on Instagram
like I'm a comedian like well actually
you know what I'm coming on those
communities I do laugh a lot
I don't have like that I don't do that
like look at something you know somebody
[__] falls on their ass
and as he goes down he grabs some fat
woman's dress and rips it you know and I
just don't look at it and be like that's
funny you know what I mean like I
laughed my ass off I love slapstick okay
I'm stupid
I'm not a smart person so people falling
down hurting themselves
you know not injured but just like ah
you know Peter Griffin kind of
is [__] hilarious to me but anyway
last night I was going through um
I kind of got away from reading
I brought a book on [__] um my
vacation because I was just like you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be like
a 35 year old woman who just got out of
a relationship I'm gonna stick my toes
in the sand I'm gonna read a
I'm gonna read a book about
you know the murder of Indians that we
stuck on land that we didn't think was
worth anything that is now worth oil
then there was a bunch of oil on it
that's a good summertime read right
and um
my kids were just I don't they just wore
me out every day we like swim every
single day which was [__] awesome
but um I have found that that's a myth
like we're going to do this we'll do
that we're going to wear the kids out no
you're not you're going to wear yourself
up and then you're gonna have two kids
with like they're like self-charging
batteries
you know like the more that they do that
the money it like just stays charged
so
last night
I did exactly what I said I was going to
do is I was just on my phone watching
Instagram videos and of course now I
can't remember any of them because they
were all like 40 seconds long
but um
oh what was that one that I saw I was
[__] dying
there was someone saying what it's like
to have a three-year-old
and she was like cooking something and
then they just cut over and somebody had
like a baby like a picture of a baby and
you know they do that thing like
remember how Conan O'Brien used to do
the mouths on that bit but they were
just like you know you do like Bill
Clinton and all of that they did that
with the baby and they were singing
ah what was that [__] some butchering
the whole thing
it was singing a Sam Smith song in the
in the baby through the f word in it
something about him coming into your
[__] house
and it was so stupid and so Random
but I thought it was like brilliant I'm
like how the [__] did they come up then
so you know something
actually I'm quite bitching about hacky
coming comedy on Instagram because it's
kind of like stand-up comedy you know
what I mean there's a handful of really
good comics and then there's some on
their way to being in and then there's
and there's the other stuff
why is Instagram just like the industry
that I'm in
I'm hearing rumors that the strike's
going to be over soon
we'll see
oh by the way you know I do that
Thursday podcast with furzie but the new
Zoom agreement is that they [__] own
all the content that you record on it
they own the content right and then they
got some side deal evidently with some
AI company
because they're just for each person
like it's so [__] nuts for each
person not even anybody like you know in
the public eye each person they're gonna
like create a file and see how you work
you know how your brain works and way
the way you think and all of this type
of [__] like these people
are gonna
phase all of it this is it right here
the robot Replacements are coming
and I got to tell you I'm all for it
you think I give you think I still want
to do the [__] road I'll have
Gallagher too out there doing my [__]
act I don't give a [__]
let some other [__] take all the money I
don't give a [__]
all right
hey I loved your showdown in Anaheim
that wasn't me
that was AI me
I was sitting on the porch [__]
watching John Bonham videos
I started a garden in my backyard
I'm growing my own vegetables I'll do it
in a second because the entertaining
thing is gonna be
is um
you know there's some stupid clip going
around with this guy is just just
stroking the balls of capitalism and it
was like from like 40 years ago
and he's talking about you have to have
a free market you gotta have a free
market this is the best freaking thing
and it's everybody's like this guy like
is like Nostradamus acting like
capitalism is working acting like there
is a free market there isn't you're
getting bullied by Robert Barons since
the 1800s and they've slowly been
swallowing up everything getting rid of
the [__] middle class but you know
that we still got the songs
God bless
you know I ages my god-given right to
say [__] you [__] with an AR-15 and
[__] transition to being something
you know all his [__] [__] we're
screaming and yelling about it meanwhile
these [__] are taking all the money so
what I'm enjoying
is that once they destroy everyone below
the line
you know
below the line which is anybody that
doesn't meet under [__] [__] Mountain
every year at the Bilderberg Group once
they destroy all of us and replace all
of us
you know
I'm sure that that's like their end game
all right that is it
we finally have what we want
a bunch of slaves
who'll do whatever we can we don't have
to pay them and they will never Revolt
they'll just do what we want and then
what's going to happen is like
the disease of capitalism is you're
never happy with what you have you just
want more and more and more at least the
way it's set up every quarter
we must increase the profits or else
that's considered a failure we don't
care who we have to crush right
eventually that's going to turn on them
and that's when it's going to get fun
you know when AI me comes in
you know because I've been told to and I
go in and I snap the neck the the
virtual me goes in and snaps the neck of
whoever's running all these [__]
Banks
and then it's going to get all the way
down
to one [__] person
it's going to be him
because you know it's going to be him
you know according to the Bible
it wasn't him
it was him who made all the stuff and
then did this other stuff too
um
it's going to be him and all the AI
people and then it's going to be it and
he's going to own all the stadiums he's
going to own all the food he's going to
own all the water all the land all the
ocean all the he's going to own all of
it
he's going to go over and he's going to
sit down
and his Lazy Boy and he's going to go
ah
that's gonna be it
that's going to be the end of the human
race
the last person sitting down in a lazy
boy
with a stuck handle
and an exhale that that's my prediction
all right
and if you graph it on the [__] around
and find out chart
um
I just you know it's something that's
what I wish was was done more because
hack comedians we call each other out
all the time
now I have to tell you that back in the
day uh
at the cellar
all those knuckleheads down there
they started this thing called hack
Court
and if somebody challenged your joke you
had to take your joke to hack Court in
front of a jury of your peers and you
had
you had to defend your joke and the
other comedian had said why it was hacky
why it was unoriginal and what they
hated about your joke and then you had
to stand there and you ought to defend
it
and even if you won
even if you won you could never [__]
do it again at the cellar because they
were so in your [__] after you defended
a joke for the better part of an hour
um
you know what I wish I did back in the
day I just said listen I'm not going to
defend my any of my ACT I just want to
throw myself on the mercy of this court
and then they would have laughed and
then I wanted to trash all of them for
being hacks
I used to get into I used to make fun of
Patrice for going on stage and
pretending that he that he that he reads
I remember he had this stupid [__]
joke used to drive me nuts he'd be like
in America
they got capitalism
but Russia that [__] is just like and
then he would just shrug his shoulders
like what the [__] and everyone would go
nuts laughing and all that type of stuff
and I used to tease him and go you're
tricking all these white people into
thinking that you're reading
like wow that big black guy you know
it's about you know
he knows about different forms of
government he was talking that's right
he was talking about four uh different
countries I'm like no he wasn't no he
wasn't he just brought him up that's all
that happened there
one of the few times I got him
um
I think my record against him was like
one in thirty six thousand no no I beat
him another time too I beat him another
time too and I beat him so bad he
actually got mad
um
anyway
plowing ahead what did I want to talk
about
um
I know
I didn't bring this up so back when I
was down Martha's Vineyard
this buddy of mine I did a movie with
goes by the name of Joe McIntyre was in
a group called New Kids on the Block was
doing a solo tour is doing a solo tour
and he was at the Cape Cod Melody tent
and um
I ran into him over the summer
or earlier this year and he said hey you
know any chance you can be back East he
goes I would love for you to come on and
do a few minutes on that show and I was
like dude I would love to so it turns
out when he was there I was at Martha's
Vineyard
so we came over for the night
and uh
that's one of my favorite venues
because it's it's deceivingly large
I forget what it holds but when you
because it's in the round you it feels
like 300 people and it's more like you
know 3 000 people I don't know what the
hell it is
um right now somebody's going to
Wikipedia and they'll send me the exact
number oh maybe you should get [__]
video
um so anyway I go there
and I show up
and lo and behold who else is there
Donnie Wahlberg right who's going to be
like a surprise guest
and I'm not gonna lie to you the whole
time I'm going over there I'm thinking
about
the new kids crowd and I'm and my stand
up I'm like I don't see a point where
this is going to intersect
like
um
and I kind of told Nia as we were going
over I go I'm not gonna lie to dude like
I'm kind of [__]
nervous about this and she's like
don't call me dude and I'm like sorry
when I get nervous
I just talked to you like you're one of
my guy friends and she's like well I
don't appreciate that
and I was like really
none of that happened it all happened in
my head I just said I'm nervous about
this [__] right so I went over there
um I think I met Donnie briefly like 10
years ago in the North End I want to say
Joe brought me out he went to go meet
him for lunch or something like that I
met him briefly but this is the first
time I actually met him great [__]
guy
um
got to shoot the [__] with him and I got
to watch the crowd you know go nuts when
he went up on stage but before they
brought him up on stage oh and he was
super nice
to my wife it was just they have both of
them just couldn't have been nicer and
then the crew of people that they hung
around with like the vibe was great you
could just see this is like 30 years of
being on the road everybody gets along
everybody has their quirks and
everybody's busting balls it was just
[__] awesome
and it was so chill that I kind of
forgot that it had to go on so
the show starts
[__] Joey Matt goes down there these
chicks are [__] screaming it's like
Beetle Mania
[Laughter]
I'm like that all right I grew up and
the shows I went to I don't know if the
chicks were screaming the [__]
guitarists were so goddamn loud that's
why my ears [__] ring forever you
didn't know what was going on I didn't
know what they were saying
you know it was just like it was so
[__] loud it was actually really
stupid how the like the level of loud
that the show was was so stupid but that
was back
when it was like if it's too loud you're
too old man
um dumb [__] like that and people didn't
understand
that from the first note that they were
giving everybody permanent
um hearing damage
which is true anything 120 decibels you
get up to that level it's immediate
permanent you might not notice it
um
but there's some degree of of uh
permanent damage
so anyway yeah I never heard women
scream like so they're [__] screaming
and I'm just sitting there I'm like
freaking out
so I was saying to Donnie oh dude I
could be honest with like I don't know
what the [__] I'm gonna do out there
he's ah you're gonna be fine you're
gonna be fine you know
and then my head I'm going he's just
saying that
he's being a good guy and he's just
saying that I'm not going to be fine
like so much of my [__] is misogynistic
and that [__] sounds
that crowd sounds like there's not one
guy in it
so anyways as I'm sitting back there I'm
freaking out
you know
who sends me a text message before I go
out to reassure me
huh to let me know you know this is why
I love her
I'm backstage she knew I was backstage
freaking out
you know because I didn't want to go out
there and bomb and then say something
[__] up and get into it with someone
in the crowd then I'm [__] up
somebody else's show
so I'm really nervous
so
and my wife knew it so she reached out
and this is the
this is the text she sent me
it's a tent full of women that love Joey
Bibi don't piss them off they're really
happy
and then she's with two crying emojis
after it like laughing crying
and um
I was just like
all right what am I gonna do and at the
last thing as I was walking down there
to go on
I was like well I'm in Martha's Vineyard
I'll just make fun of the fat [__] down
there eating ice cream that's what I'll
start off with
you know even though there's some fat
people in the crowd
the fact that I'm not talking about them
on the mainland I'm talking about them
in Martha's Vineyard I think I'll get
away with it so I went up there there's
actually a clip
it was weird I got on stage and I was
immediately comfortable
um I don't know why probably because Joe
has such a [__] Cool vibe
and uh
I messed around
what did I say I can't remember what I
said I was talking about I was making
fun of Joe because he had to go change
outfits like share or something like
that and
um
so I go into my act and I just not even
my act just riff and I start making fun
of fat [__] eating ice cream on
Martha's Vineyard and they just went
with it
and for like I only did like you know
seven minutes I think I was supposed to
do like 10 but Joe came back quickly
thank God
and um
I could not have had a bit I had such a
good time and he came on stage and we
were joking around
and he was like trying to say something
nice to me and of course I cut him off
and he was like going like dude you
cannot accept a compliment and people
will kind of laugh and watching us go
back and forth
and
yada yada yada I got off stage and uh I
had a high like I [__] did an hour I
was so [__] relieved
that I didn't bomb I always think of
myself first and then secondly that I
didn't mess up any of
you know Joe's evening or anything like
that and then I went around you know I
walked around the tent I went around
back and I ran into Nia and she had a
big grin in her face she was like that
was great that was great I was like I
know I go I didn't piss him off she goes
you didn't they loved you I was like all
right
and we both started laughing
and then we we sat in the crowd we
watched the rest of the show and uh
and then I had that whole excitement
thing because I was like these [__]
people don't know that Donnie's gonna
come out and they're all going to lose
their [__] and that's what they did I
had my earplugs in
not because of how loud the show was
because of how loud that they were
screaming so they put on a great show
and um
I don't know it was really cool it was
like watching you know two Comics that
had known each other for a long time
like their Vibe and their chemistry on
stage is really cool so
um got to do that got to see that show
got to meet all those cool people so
thank you to Joy McIntyre
um and all of those guys Donnie and all
of them for letting me hang out
um
that was really cool not to mention my
wife is a huge new kids fan she was like
right in their wheelhouse when did they
come out like the early 90s so my wife
would have been like 13 14 so that was
just over
um
so that was really fun I would I will
tell you the boat ride across was scary
um the Seas were a little rough like you
can't you can't believe what a [__]
boat can take this thing was like going
slap slap slap on the thing I'm like one
of these things is just gonna make this
[__] thing fall apart by the way I
watched a video
on uh the internet
that I don't even know why I watched it
I know why because I'm so afraid of
sharks
you know and I got a gig coming up in
Greece and I love the Mediterranean Sea
and people always say you don't have to
worry about sharks so then I Google
shark attacks in the Mediterranean and I
quickly find out you do have to worry
about sharks
not like ridiculously worry about them
but they are it you are you're on the
menu dude I'll tell you that right now
that is my [__] if you're not jumping in
a [__] pool you are on the menu and
if you jump in the pool
in Florida you're on the [__] menu
because you have no idea what exotic pet
your [__] neighbor has that somehow
got free and is now [__] chilling
with just its eyes above the surface of
the water and as you go in to do a
[__] Cannonball or a can opener
that's the one I never understood the
can opener which was The Cannonball
except one leg was straight
it was really boring
sort of like the Camaro Rally Sport
you know
Band-Aid color with the [__] V6
then you'd pull up next to a Z28
and you just you didn't feel like a
[__] man
um anyway let me um
let me uh let me be today to take me I
was looking up [__] about the Eagles
today oh Eagles not the Eagles Eagles
they're doing their final they're doing
their farewell tour
I don't know why oh I know why because I
was on Instagram and I saw three people
harmonizing
um
Take It to the Limit I believe and they
were killing it I was like oh what's
going on with the Eagles you know you
know bass player just died
Glenn Frey died a while ago what's going
on they're on they're on their final
tour
and I was reading about them that what's
weird about them is their first few
albums
did well but not great and then they put
out a greatest hits album and it sold
the most albums of anything ever
so like 38 million copies I'm thinking
didn't Back in Black sell more than that
maybe they men of the 70s
I don't know
um but I'd like to go see them because I
always loved Don Henley's voice and I
also loved his drumming
um
but they used to always be battling
they're sort of like uh the American
Oasis except they're not Brothers
[Laughter]
just always getting in [__] fights
and [__] and the whole crowd's like can
you [__] [__] just get along and
write some music like what is the
[__] problem
who plays in a band
who listens to this can I ask you a
question like what is the [__]
problem I get it in your 20s and [__]
like that
but once you get into your 30s like your
time is over you don't realize it but
your time is over you can put on
sunglasses and [__] walk around
looking like a giant mosquito like that
one band did
and change your sound and all of that
[__] but really you know you had your
[__] time
and it's over right see then you you
[__] uh
what are you gonna do go back and get a
real job
just put the [__] band back together
talk out your [__]
go on the road and sing your [__] hit
right
um
anyway I think I would definitely go see
them I I really like uh
I really like um
I really like Don Henley
um
well and he's also a guy from Dallas too
and he liked the Cowboys remember that
back in the day when I liked the Cowboys
before Jimmy Johnson I like Tom Landry
Cowboys
um anyway there was one other thing I
want to tell you about oh
did I talk to you about doing
Springfield and Halifax
oh I didn't know I talked about Halifax
on Monday I did I talked about that in
Springfield all right with that let me
do let me do a read here
such an [__] I always do that I
always end up closing
the [__] record thing and then I
gotta splice two things together I
wasn't even trying to do that all right
here's a live read everybody
a g i
Alpha Gulf well uh one our new partner
is ag-1 the daily foundational nutrition
supplement that supports whole body
Health why take a bunch of different
things when you can just mix one scoop
of powder and water once a day
or maybe in your Loveless marriage and
anything that takes a little bit longer
and keeps you away from the other person
maybe that's a reason
AGI was designed with ease in mind
yeah read through the [__]
the subtext of that was designed with
ease in mind even a mouth breathing
[__] could stick this into a cup of
liquid so you can live healthier and
better without having to complicate your
routine I don't want to think ag-1
replace replaces your multivitamin Jesus
Christ is there anything it's harder to
swallow than a multivitamin
do they so they still like the size of a
[__]
I don't know what what is this a beetle
probiotic and More in one simple dream
your multivitamin your probiotic
right you got the vitamins for your body
the probiotic for your gut which is also
part of your body see this is why they
make it simple because there's guys like
me out there all in one simple drinkable
habit
is that the right word there
uh he1 is a foundational nutrition
supplement that delivers comprehensive
nutrients to support whole body Health
you already said that science driven
formulation of vitamins probiotics and
Whole Food Source nutrients I guess I'm
just supposed to read one of those
let's get let's let's get to the meat of
the order here every scoop is I'm gonna
make one of those [__] quick edit
videos with this thing me putting a
scoop of it in
every scoop is packed with 75 vitamins
minerals
and probiotics
are you probiotics no I'm pro-choice
and Whole Food Source ingredients of
high quality that gives you major
benefits like gut and mood support
am I Roofing my wife with some of this
oh geez boosted energy and even
healthier looking skin hair
what
what would you guys do if I started
taking this thing and then all of a
sudden the next time you came out to my
show I just had a full head like a
[__] lion's mane
of red hair
and I had like some sort of chick
apparatus in it you know you know the
guys with the gray hair it's not that he
hadn't it's not enough that they have
great hair they got to put on like uh
what is the thing like that keeps it out
of your eyes and it's like right behind
you right behind your ears you know you
put it on your forehead and then it whip
it goes back what is that called
um one of those things
you know if I had an hour to find out
what that was on the internet
or else I had to spend the rest of my
life in jail that would be better than
any Tom Cruise movie
uh hair and nails AGI is raised
is raising the standard for quality in
the supplement category ag-1 helps you
build your health Foundation First if
you want to take ownership of your
health try ag1 and get a free one-year
supply of Supply supply of vitamin D and
five free ag1 travel packs with your
purchase go to drinkag1.com that's
drinkag1.com
and check it out all right that's it
that's the podcast have a great weekend
you [__] and I'll talk to you on Monday
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast from
Monday August 17th
2015. why did I just say 17th like like
something major happened
you know on this day and this day 200
years ago
Christopher Columbus had jockish itch
which was fatal back in the 17th how the
[__] would he still be alive bill
he probably died as scurvy in the see
1492 we came over here and hacked off
the in the [__] Native Americans
hands
you know
probably an unprotected sex
introduce some sort of I don't know
I don't know what genital genetic
genitalia scabies is that how you say it
I don't know people
this has got to be a record how quickly
did this 53 seconds in and it just went
right off the [__] rails this podcast
is over
[__] over Jesus Christ
anyway I was talking about August 17th
just the way I said that 17th and I got
all panicky like why did I say it like
something important happened
and then that [__] debacle happened
anyways what's going on
how are you
um it's the 17th day of August in the
year of Our Lord
this is the year of the uh cockatoo I
believe in the Chinese calendar
they have cockatoos over there
I don't know
I I've been to Hong Kong I didn't see
any
I was only there for a day
um anyways so oh Billy fat tits
the [__] pasty Adventure
I've been I've been on a tear here and
as I told you last week I [__] up my
knee
my knee I [__] the thing up uh
skipping rope
right and I guess my [__] leg muscles
got all tight and it started yanking my
old ass knee you know in the wrong
direction I started like you know just
hobbling out to the car
you know tippy-toeing down the street
you know into the bathroom
let me take that old man piss in the
middle of the night
to wake up from a dream
you know
what you drink what do you dream about
at my age no going to a farmer's market
they still have tomatoes left yeah
that's a dream to me
I wake up aroused when I have that dream
[Music]
it's a sad it's a sad [__] case
but anyway so I stretched out and did
all that [__] but still I uh I kind of
[__] up on my diet a couple days
um
my uh my wife you know was asking hey
why don't we hang out and go do
something so we went to a museum and I
[__] hate museums I absolutely
[__] hate I've told you about this
before I hate museums with the [__]
passionate how quiet it is in there I
hate people standing reading that little
card next to that [__] painting that
I swear to God it's like I did something
like that when I was five
see you know can't somebody just go back
to painting a cow in a field
you know what I mean does everything
just have to be like just
a smearing of Colors oh what the [__]
these people are so dumb they're sitting
there staring at it acting like they see
something
what are you looking at
that's a light blue that's a darker blue
and there's an even darker blue
on that big Square [__] canvas I get
it he took different shades of blue
what does it say it say says nothing
says the guy knows how to color in a
[__] square I knew how to do that
this guy a long time ago he explained it
to me he goes well the difference is
because I'd be like a little kid could
[__] do that and he goes the
difference is a little kid can't drug uh
an amazing picture like these people
that make these abstract things can
they're choosing
they're choosing to to create that way
it's like choosing to do what [__]
draw like a five-year-old
so like I I know how to talk like an
adult sort of if I go on stage and start
telling jokes like a five-year-old all
of a sudden I'm I should be in a museum
telling my jokes
knock knock
come on you're supposed to say who's
there I'm [__] stand in the corner
and all of a sudden I'm uh I'm comedy's
Picasso
I don't know whatever we went there and
she actually wanted to go see this short
film
um that this guy made I don't know who
the [__] I can't never remember
anybody's [__] name but it it was
about la
and growing up in LA and uh down in
Compton and everything like that and uh
I love anything that
is not a messy [__] painting and it's
also like history of Los Angeles because
there's so little history of it they
just [__] like I said before in the
park they just pay right over the [__]
you know Robert Kennedy got assassinated
down the [__] Ambassador Hotel that
thing would have been a shrine in any
other city this city [__] knocked it
down put up a school on top of it you
know what I mean somewhere in the
cafeteria there's like an x on the floor
with a guy [__] bled out I mean it's
unbelievable they just don't give a [__]
do you know they had one of the one of
the biggest acts of [__] terrorism as
far as blowing up a building and a
collapsing happened here in L.A
before 9 11 the biggest one was when
somebody blew up the [__] uh the LA
Times building the original one
and I've been all over the Internet and
I've walked all over downtown L.A I
can't find a [__] plaque or or
information anyway it's fine [__] it
they just
plowed it over with a couple of oxen and
then that's it
now they just you know they got the
[__] uh the little white Obelisk art
decoy thing look in there acting like
that's the only place they ever were
like that the [__] thing get didn't
get blown up in the middle of the night
um
so anyways that's what the [__] am I
talking about that's all so when we went
there this guy had all this uh this
footage
you know for basically like the Rodney
King era right up until now
um
I love that [__] seeing the old cars you
know back to the early 90s and everybody
wanted a [__] Nissan Maxima like that
was the goddamn car right
um
I just this little details like that and
then seeing you know the beginnings of
everybody [__] having an Impala Low
Rider and now that's almost like hacky
at this point if you actually have an
Impala Low Rider with the [__] wire
rims it's just like everybody's seen
that you know it's like owning a Mustang
or a 69 [__]
Camaro everybody you've seen a million
of them
so um anyway so we went down we watched
that and then uh she took me to this
place around the [__] corner which
was a German place that sold all these
different kinds of like brats and
sausages
and uh [__] sick ass french fries
like you like your mom made remember
those big thick [__] wedges and she
just deep fry the [__] out of them they
had that I got some sort of rabbit and
something else
[__] brought sausage whatever the
[__] you call it was absolutely
delicious I had two [__] french fries
it was like a junkie sitting in a crack
house man it was [__] brutal and I
looked over in the corner and there was
two young guys right like the [__]
mid-20s primary their [__] life can
eat McDonald's at two in the morning and
wake up with a flat stomach they were
over there these two young [__] [__]
was sitting over in the corner and they
had those giant German Oktoberfest beer
steins
and I just sat there
staring at those mugs of beer they look
glanced over a couple times they're
probably what the [__] is this guy
looking at like I wanted a fight it's
like I'm not looking at you guys I'm
looking I was like Homer Simpson just
sitting there doing them
here
and I actually asked ass [__]
waitress I was just like
how many how many ounces is that how
many beers
is that two three beers he was like two
and a half it's two and a half [__]
beers and I already fantasized about
being off the wagon this is why I'm
always gonna be a drunk because when I'm
sober I don't go oh this is amazing
falling asleep at 10 o'clock at night
and waking up with energy I don't think
that I just started thinking of how much
I'm gonna drink
when I go back to drinking and uh I
can't wait
for the [__] King season to start
because I'm going down to that [__]
place
probably take Joey bartnick
you know he's a Pittsburgh guy God knows
you know him Allah had God knows they
grew up on sausages and brats might even
[__] go with the two of them right go
down there and get one of those [__]
Giant
beers I [__] drink two of those
yeah
[__] Macy Day bloated Billy again
um so I [__] up there and then uh last
night
um I did a gig just outside of San Diego
at the Harrah's Casino Valley Center or
something like that really really like
beautiful part of California like you
come off of the five and there's all
these little mom and pop stores I was
making fun of it and [__] but it just
had like that Vibe of like small town
slash maybe a meth problem you know
which is like I guess that's what Mavery
is nowadays you know probably heroin now
all that [__] problem going on and um
and when we did the gig but uh I
actually flew down in a helicopter to
the gig I uh rented an r44
and I brought uh the opener Kevin Shea
with me and I flew down with my
instructor and uh and his brother
and uh dude it was it was the [__]
[__]
I probably lost money on the gig but I
don't give a [__] it was cool as hell we
were actually gonna land in the parking
lot they actually have like a little uh
area that they use as a helipad it's
just this corner of the parking lot we
were going to land there get out do the
gig and then the end get back in the
[__] thing and take off but the thing
was was it had all these mountains all
around it and the main street in had no
lights and there was a lot of power
lines and that type of [__] so we were
just like hey why don't we land at a
[__] local
Airport
and drive in instead considering neither
one of us has ever flown out of here you
know and those are the [__] decisions
you make
if you want to fly safely
um they actually had a mid-air Collision
down there I just saw
this little ass airport I don't know how
the [__] you don't see each other
you're not talking on the [__] radio
I don't know man that's the kind of [__]
you just like yeesh you know when you
start thinking you know stuff which is
always dangerous in any [__] business
we start yeah you know I can [__]
kind of keep this thing one of the
hardest things were your first fly is is
staying at a consistent altitude
which is supposed to do in a helicopter
is basically look at your manifold
pressure gauge and how whatever inches
you're pulling uh really sounds like I'm
jerking off here but uh whatever the
it's measured in like inches of mercury
so say if you if you're 21 and you look
over at your uh your vs vertical speed
indicator if it's at zero
um
you just then you just dial it in and
you just keep it okay 21 inches is what
I need to pull and I'll and keep the
[__]
uh goddamn cyclic at where I'm at but I
always end up [__] it up and if I
don't look at it for a couple minutes I
I used to go up like 300 or down or
descend 300 feet now I'm kind of within
like 100 feet so I kind of felt better
about that but uh so anyway so I flew
down there and then we drove like to
another 25 minutes did the gig had a
great [__] time great crowd
and uh then we drove back to the airport
and [__] flew back man and uh
flew back from just outside of San Diego
we got back in about 35 minutes flying
over all of this [__] traffic
and uh just flew basically right along
the coast the whole way up
and
um it was cool to do that actually kind
of
you know he was teaching me sort of some
instrument stuff where I'm not
instrument rated and of course that
piqued my [__] interest now so uh why
the hell not I might do that next but uh
as you fly in at night like it's
obviously way different during the day
and I was just like I was just like dude
I'm glad you're here because I would be
completely lost I don't know where I am
I just pointed up he goes see right
there because that's the Long Beach pier
you can always tell other Long Beach uh
wharfs Pierce well I don't know what the
[__] you call them they're all [__]
psychotically lit up though it's like
the third biggest
[Music]
um
Port Wharf Pier whatever the [__] you
call it in the world I guess so it's
always all lit up and there's all kinds
of [__] Xboxes and sex slaves and
blood diamonds going in and out of there
every [__] day so it's always lit up
and we ended up landing at uh Long Beach
after it was closed which is pretty
[__] cool and they got this thing I
forget how many times you click it but
when we took off the airport was already
closed so all the [__] lights were
out and everything
and uh on the cyclic he just [__]
click
you know we basically if you're gonna
talk to the tower you just click it like
seven or nine times I forget and when
you do that all the lights come on
the whole [__] field lights up it's
the [__] so
that's what I did last night huh not too
shabby uh but anyways
and you know what Kevin Shea was really
[__] chill
I thought he was going to be freaking
out that I was flying he actually said
he did a good job and he actually he
said this thing where he doesn't freak
out when I'm taking off when when he's
taking off when he's up there he says
when whenever the plane or whatever he's
in goes to land that's when he freaks
out which I thought was kind of
interesting to just be afraid then
um anyways I'm babbling here uh so
I was talking about oh yeah so that
night I [__]
you know we had to leave like around 3
30 and flew down about four o'clock so
uh that was right around dinner time and
then I got to a casino and I'm just like
they were like we got Mexican food and
I'm like all right hey you want tacos
yes
how about a burrito okay
hahaha
that sounded like little John there and
I [__] uh
you know [__]
just inhaled a chicken [__] burrito
it was it was actually really good I
have it I think was because I haven't
eaten like that since the Fourth of July
I haven't had any just [__] food
that's gonna make you a fat [__] so it
was delicious uh but everybody else
there was also saying it was good and
then I I
was in the back of my head going dude
don't take it too far now
don't take it too far so then I reach
for a taco and I only had one and um
so anyways I came back this morning
and I got on the scale after I took my
dog around the block and then went on
like an hour and a half [__] hike and
weighed myself with an empty stomach so
I would actually make weight this week I
know the second I had a glass of water I
[__] went up like three pounds but uh
I'm gonna say I'm about 171 pounds the
scale read
168 170 and 169.4 depending on where I
put it
so uh
I just took the middle one 169.4 and
then because I I had you know hadn't
eaten breakfast I hadn't drank any water
I just added like [__] a couple two
three pounds so I'll say I'm 171. I
might be a little Londa I might be a
little over but there you go go [__]
yourself man I've lost almost 17 pounds
of [__] booze
Burgers ice cream potato chips and all
of that [__] [__] and uh I feel great
and I can't wait to lose the rest of
this whatever the [__] it's gonna be
whenever I lose the last
I still can grab a nice [__] handful
here man whenever I lose the rest of
this and then the second I get a nice
flat stomach I'm gonna get myself a
gallon of ice cream and one of those
beer steins and I'm gonna go right back
up again
what is the point of losing all the
weight if you're not going to go back
and indulge and become a complete fat
[__] again right
I don't know maybe you do maybe you're
doing it to have a lifestyle change I'm
just trying to just you know
I don't want to be 40 pounds overweight
so I'll just [__] drop that to 20 and
I'll go back to zero
and then I'll be 20 pounds overweight
again just in time for my special next
year
big [__] booze head coming at you
and I would never do that to you
um all right let's get to uh
is there any [__] advertising for
this week Jesus Christ I've [__] on so
many of them I don't I don't know what
is what is left
do I have anything
oh there we are three three little ones
remember back in the day you used to
have six
what happened oh these people stick with
me through thick and through thin they
don't give a [__] what I say I love this
company these people are [__] cool
here we go uh
um all right let's talk about the local
news shall we uh yeah we got to check in
our own our old friend there you
remember remember what's his face that's
his face Rodney Dangerfield members
doctor Dr Vinnie boombots he'd always be
talking about him well we hear on the
podcast like to talk about our old
friend Ole Anthony Anthony Monsanto see
what that Goomba is up to this [__]
this month do you know that those guys
are over in uh India right now
Monsanto and they have like a sister
company right now and they're getting
they're getting sued I believe are they
getting taken to court because India
said we don't want genetically modified
food can you believe that they didn't
want their food altered
they probably looked at all the [__]
poison people in this country and
they're like well we don't want to be
like that
we already have a population problem the
last thing we need is these [__]
[__] [__] with our Curry
right a chicken a rice a [__]
eggplant all that [__] right
so what what is what does Anthony do
he's a [__] he doesn't give a [__] he
goes in there anyways
and without permission allegedly
takes a strain of their own eggplant and
genetically [__] modifies the thing
and guess what they got [__] busted
so now it's a big thing whether they're
going to go to trial if people are going
to go to jail and all that and you know
what Anthony's doing he's just throwing
money around over there because he's
going to find some corrupt [__]
politician who's going to say [__] this
I'd rather have a big house
and [__] over a billion of my own
countrymen
just so I can have a [__] jacuzzi and
a couple of goddamn [__] come over
there can you believe that
um
Scotland actually outlawed genetically
altered food I wish this country would
it's [__] unbelievable I'll tell you
one thing right now because I'm not a
well-read guy but I can I can predict
[__] I can guarantee you that nobody who
has any [__] remote shot
of becoming president
basically I mean a candidate in the
Democratic or the Republican Party
nobody is going to bring up old Anthony
they're not going to [__] do it
they're not going to bring up how all
these [__]
throw all these money all this money at
all these [__] politicians so that
they can use words like organic
homegrown and all of that [__] illegally
when it isn't
and it's just a bunch of [__] poison
you know what I mean
I think it's [__] up dude
I'm gonna go out on a limb and just say
that's really [__] up so I wouldn't
keep an eye on that man because I went
over there to India obviously and I as I
talked about before I did a gig and the
[__] people are cool as [__] they're
funny as hell and um I don't I can't
explain it I went over there and I can't
explain it the way the [__] people
couldn't explain how great the underwear
was or the shaving cream whatever the
[__] it was
I know I just felt uh I just liked it
over there
um so I like the people and I hope that
their food doesn't become [__] up like
the food is over here and as dumb as I
am I am speaking from experience because
as I told you guys I ate and drank like
[__] Ernest Hemingway
when I was over in France earlier this
year for 10 days and I put on only four
[__] pounds I was crushing beers
Rich [__] meals I was eating [__]
homemade cream puffs
every day
and I came home and all I gained was
four pounds if I did that [__] in this
country I would have [__] gained 15
17 [__] pounds
um
telling you man this I don't know
there's something going on believe me I
don't believe me I don't give a [__] I'm
just throwing it out there and uh so
anyway if you guys have any good stories
about all our good friend there Anthony
we'll see and Anthony Monsanto we'll see
uh you know we'll try to just keep an
eye on them
see what he's see what the [__] he's
been up to
and so as I mentioned this time of year
I actually start to pay attention to
baseball because I [__] love October
baseball you know they they [__] uh
put all the extra mics in there and the
crowds sound amazing it's cold you know
the trophy's on the line [__]
legendary [__] happens I can't wait you
know so we're coming out of the dog days
this summer here so I'm starting to pay
attention so for those of you not paying
attention my [__] Red Socks
I have not I've watched one game this
year they're 52 and 65. a .44 winning
percentage they had 12 and a half games
out
and they've played 117 games what do
they play 162 so they got about 40
[__] five games left oh geez
oh my God if we won all 45 we could only
win there's no way we can win 100 games
this year
we need to go about 40 and fives I think
we got a shot at winning the division
actually no the [__] Yankees are 64.
in 52 we're not going to catch them but
12 and a half games out
yeah I'd say this is a wrap Toronto's a
half game out loving that I hope they
keep plummeting I love Baltimore and I
love [__] Tampa Bay
I like those I don't like I don't like
Toronto
they've been blowing in the [__]
League what are you doing here you know
get your own sport
you don't see us playing your sport do
we do you
[__] Red Sox lost again today
lost again today ten to eight put up
eight runs and still couldn't [__]
hold them off
um all right let's get to the standings
here
how's Kansas City doing
Kansas City first [__] place best
record in the [__] American League I
love it
we went five and five our last ten
Yankees went four and six Toronto went
eight and two they're surging Kansas
City seven and three
that's [__] tremendous
Detroit's four and a half back
Minnesota's one and a half bad guy you
got yourself a race there when the [__]
did the Astros go to the American League
what the [__] happened there who
switched
Milwaukee did a long time ago
all right that's [__] weird
Washington Atlanta Miami
Philly St Louis
I don't got time to figure this [__]
[__] out all right so Kansas City's my
team
love to see Kansas City I'm liking the
Mets
they're long tortured [__] fans even
though they're New Yorkers I don't give
a [__]
Philadelphia Jesus Christ what happened
in Philly
St Louis is always [__] there oh God
they're gonna make a run again Jesus St
Louis is there what a what a [__]
what an organization I'm sorry this is
boring as [__] you just listen to me
looking at the goddamn stats here
um
all right here's something [__] up you
guys see that story on Patrick Kane I
shouldn't even set his [__] name
that Patrick Kane story where he's uh
getting he's charged with allegedly uh
where the hell is it here let's make
sure I get this right
um
for God's sakes where the [__] is it
basically he's charged with allegedly
raping somebody
so some douchebag is saying that the NHL
needs to suspend him it's like that
right there is the reason why not only
should the victim be protected the the
person being accused should be protected
he shouldn't put the guy's name and face
and drag him through the [__] mud
you know am I the only guy who remembers
that Rolling Stone story and that's not
the only time that that has happened
all right so In fairness
considering what this guy has to lose
he should be treated with the same
respect as the alleged Victim Because
it's all a legend
you shouldn't be [__]
this is it's none of my [__] business
right now
you know what I mean let it go to trial
have the whole thing come out in the
[__] wash and in the end
if he's found guilty then not only
suspend him he got he can't have a
[__] convicted rapist in you that's
the end of his career yeah that's it my
voice just cracked it that's the end of
his [__] career
I'm not trying to uh attack either
person here I'm just saying in the
future they really need to start [__]
doing this because
let's just play Devil's Advocate the way
this blogger is is [__] talking about
Patrick Kane like he's already been
convicted
and just sitting there oh we hold our
athletes in [__] blah blah blah and
we just can't wrap our heads around that
condescending [__] speak
you know like I'm sitting there with the
poster of him on my [__] wall in a
racing car bed
um
Jay do people in power take advantage of
it wow what else do you know there
[__] no-name blogger
um anyways
I think you know
that they shouldn't put the they also
should protect the accused because this
guy has so much to [__] lose and the
bottom line is once you get accused of
that [__] it's [__] over
even if they find out even if the victim
were to come out and just say hey I made
the whole thing up
I don't know what I was thinking sorry
about that [__] see you right and of
course you can say that as a woman and
not go to [__] jail after you just
ruined a guy's life
um sorry I was just in a mood you know
then I went out and I got some breakfast
and I felt better and I realized you
know what he didn't write me actually uh
I kind of enjoyed it
so anyways that's what I'm saying you
shouldn't say either person's name
and then you know
when it goes to trial if the person's
convicted then tar and feather them
I think that's more than fair
don't you I don't know
so anyways so let me so here's the thing
if Patrick Kane
is acquitted of this if it doesn't go to
trial don't be a [__] [__]
and yell some [__] at him at games when
you know when your team's playing them
because you're mad you can't beat the
[__] Blackhawks don't be a douche all
right but like I said if he [__] did
it you know he should go to jail and uh
rot there right
laughs
um
I don't know let's [__] move on here
uh what else do I got how many much
[__] done 35 minutes okay
um
what else did I want to talk about I
think that was basically it
uh uh I got anything else do I got
anything coming up I don't I'm just
still [__] uh editing um
editing this F is for family
uh
uh I gotta go back in tomorrow and all
that type of [__] I can't wait for you
guys to see this [__] I can't wait I
believe I gotta wait until December to
find out if you guys think it's good or
it sucks
but uh anyways oh you know what I should
do you guys mind if I read you some of
my [__] dates here
I got coming up I gotta hype these
[__] things I just added a whole run
through Texas
where the hell is it there we go okay
here we go here we go billboard.com
everybody oh billbird.com
um all right September 11th in Los
Angeles I'm doing the Jack radio comedy
show
September 21st I'm in Austin Texas
September 23rd I'm in Houston Texas
September 25th I'm in San Antonio Texas
and on the 24th I believe that's a
Saturday I'm going to the uh Texas
Longhorn OSU game so I'll see you out in
the parking lot hit me up man if you're
[__] smoking some meat or whatever
let me know let me stand by you smoker
like some stray cat
you know I'll throw 20 bucks towards
your tailgate oh 40 bucks whatever you
need let us buy in me and verzia coming
through town let us buy in
all right but don't don't [__] reach
out to me if you got some [__] here
this is Texas I would accept [__] in
some other [__] state but this is
Texas you guys are known for this [__]
um
we'd love to come by we'll bring some
[__] top shelf booze we're going to
be rooting for the Longhorns we'll have
a good [__] time all right and then
in the end of October
um October 22nd I'm going to be in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
uh the Heinz Hall for the Performing
Arts October 23rd I'm going to play
Playhouse squares
State Theater in Cleveland Ohio October
24th ah I'm going to Indianapolis
Indiana
country
uh I'll make sure I have enough air in
the [__] microphone playing the MERS
theater October 25th I'm in Detroit at
the Fox Theater
uh the 26th I'm gonna be in Grand Rapids
Michigan 28th Minneapolis Minnesota 29th
the Chicago theater
um and then on November 6th I'm gonna be
in Philly haven't been there in a long
[__] time
usually play the Tower Theater I'm going
to be playing another Wells Fargo Center
this time
so I got a brand new hour of [__] I'm
gonna be [__] doing a bunch of stand
up between now and then so I give you
guys your money's worth so uh please by
all means come on out to the shows I
would appreciate it all right and with
that let's get back to the let's get to
your questions this week I think I've
run my mouth enough about myself
and what I fed up too and the things
that I find important
um all right fat shaming success story
all right oh that's a rough one you know
all right hey Bill I'm six feet tall and
five months ago I weighed 320 pounds Big
Boy Jesus buddy all right I'm now down
to 243 and trying to get around trying
to get down to around 200. I've been
using your self-shaming method and it's
uh it's obvious that it works I [__]
love that self-shaming wins
you're getting in there huh you're
taking your shirt off standing in the
mirror jumping up and down look what you
did look at it
and then you [__] build yourself up
turn it around he said even though my
people tell me I look good I don't let
up on myself thanks for the motivation
and go [__] yourself yeah man you got to
do it
you got to stay on yourself and this is
the thing too I look this is a
psychologically how I look at it I look
at it like uh each each week is a game
like in the NFL season all right I get
on the scale I figure out how much
[__] weight I need to lose all right
I needed to lose like a good [__] you
know I was a good oh Jesus you know my
fighting weights you know when I had a
last time I had a flat stomach I was
between like 162 165 so I was up to 187
so I needed to lose a good 20 25 pounds
all right so I figured you know I'll
lose two to three a [__] week I'm
looking at a good 10 weeks 10 10 week
season here so what I do is if I lose I
have it on the on the calendar I write
the weight that I'm at and every Sunday
I just write down the weight that I want
to be the next Sunday
and uh I weigh myself every day
sometimes a couple of times a day I get
[__] psychotic with it and um I try
to make weight every Sunday and I try
and I try to do it without starving
myself because then you just kind of eat
away at muscle and you become very
fleshy
very fleshy
um which is just all gelatinous and [__]
you want the muscle because I guess it
eats the fat because that's what
somebody in a bar who wasn't a [__]
nutritionist told me all right
so and then how how I do it so I don't
[__] up is because I know that there's
no way I'm gonna go 10 [__] straight
weeks and eat absolutely perfectly I
know at some point I'm gonna [__] up and
have a burrito and a taco and a [__]
brat or whatever the [__] I did
um
and I just try to immediately get back
on the stick and then that week if I
don't make weight I just I call that
week a loss and then I just look at my
record I just pretend I'm a coach all
right I was 2-0 now I'm two and one I
can't go two and two
can't go two and two then the local
[__] sport writers are gonna get is
it time to make a change you know
so uh
I won the first two weeks with this diet
I lost the next one I tried to call it a
bye week but I'll say that's a loss I
was two and one then I won the next two
weeks in a row and this week I was
looking at a loss
so instead of being five and one I was
looking at four and two and I didn't
like that number and I just went really
hardcore with the working out and trying
to eat as perfect as I could so I I just
just look at it that way and if you uh
you know if you [__] up or whatever
it's not the end of the world unless you
allow it to be and I think a lot of
people myself included is when you
when you [__] up on your diet
the next day what you have to watch out
is when you eat a bunch of Grease or
sugar or salt you're gonna wake up the
next day and you're gonna crave that
[__]
um so what you've basically started is a
little fire
that you can easily stomp out with your
[__] slippers while you're still in
your bathrobe by just making yourself a
bowl of oatmeal
or something healthy for breakfast and
then you eat that you're because you've
been eating so well You're Gonna Wanna
you're gonna
still be on that Craven uh healthy stuff
this is how it works for me okay
obviously I'm not a nutritionist I'm
none of this
no Sports Medicine nothing this is just
what's working for me I've
realized after years I think it was
stupid when people said food is a drug I
realize finally now that it is
so when I [__] up
you know and I basically in a food
version
you hit the crack pipe I just make sure
the next day that when I get up
like
before I even had like I I you know I go
for a walk I drink some water with some
lemon and that will really calm you down
you know so you don't get a [__]
Danish or go out and get some waffles or
some salty [__] eggs and cheese and
bacon and all that [__]
um
that's what's been working for me so if
you want to go from 233 243 to 200
uh just
maybe you know try that if it works for
you it works for you if it doesn't I'm
sure there's a zillion other things on
the Internet by you know professionals
but I'm happy for you man that's [__]
insane dude
that's what
320 to
that's almost 80 [__] pounds
77 pounds dude that's unbelievable good
for you man keep going all right drought
shaming
oh God hey Bill up here in Northern
California we are on tight water
restriction pretty much everyone's Lawns
are dead or mostly Brown personally it's
driving me up the wall to have a dead
ass yard but you know I'm gonna do my
part my issue is these selfish [__] who
have the [__] nerve to just flood
their goddamn Lawns like they're special
or something I want to Drought shame uh
the blatant water users in my
neighborhood but I don't want to [__]
where I eat do you have any thoughts or
advice by the way we saw your show uh
when you came to Sacramento and you
killed man we hope you come back soon oh
thank you
um
well look I never Advocate rad not
ratting somebody out
um
but it's a weird thing when when
somebody's doing something that affects
the whole tribe you know what I mean
this isn't like uh you know
the guy drove home I don't know whatever
I can't think of a [__] example this
is something that really is affecting
the entire state
um I I don't know what I would do
why don't you you leave them an
anonymous note and just say listen I'm
not trying to be a jerk but we are in a
drought
um you're not supposed to be Watering
your lawn and I'm not the kind of person
to rat somebody out that's what you do
and I would really hope that you don't
put me in a position to have to call the
local authorities about you watering the
[__] out of your [__] lawn so then
basically what you did is you went
passive aggressive you didn't rat them
out
don't make me [__] do this but at the
end of the day man I mean we're
we're in serious [__] trouble here so
that whole no snitching thing it's it's
becomes a little bit of a gray area so
why don't you give the guy a [__]
chance
you know
don't be a [__] in the letter just say
please I I don't rat people out but you
know this is
the needs of the state and the people in
the state are way bigger than you and
your yard please don't put me in a
position
you got to go walking like in True
Romance
when he [__] clasps his hand together
like whatever he says I beg you don't
put me in this position or something
whatever the [__] he said that that's
what I would do
so then you don't have to [__] rat
them out
then if you know he keeps water in his
yawn lawn I don't know what do you do
you know what you do you [__] out and
you have your wife make the call
I don't know man I I really have zero
tolerance when it comes to people uh
I don't know
I bet but look at me I flew a [__]
helicopter down to my [__] gig
and I'm not using bottled water but this
is
my instructor was saying like dude we
just [__] sent let it gas through the
atmosphere so I mean I'm a [__]
hypocrite too I don't know what to tell
you but it does bug me when everybody
else is trying to tighten the [__]
belt and there is that person just
[__] water in the [__] I'll tell you
the people in my neighborhood man
they're [__] watering the [__] out of
there I don't think I don't even have
any grass in my [__] yard you know
what I mean I got a couple of I water
the uh
I water the plants that are actually
producing food my wife likes all these
other [__] plants I was like who
gives a [__] about a plant if it's not
feed me what the [__] do I care about it
let's get him out of here right so
that's a bit of a fight but like some of
my neighbors man it's like they water
this [__] and uh what kills me is not
that they're necessarily watering it
it's that the sprinklers are so [__]
up it's just shooting out into the
street
landing on the Hot Tar and then just
evaporating
um what they're really doing is spraying
people's cars that probably just got
them washed which you're not supposed to
I haven't washed my car in [__]
months look dude we're all [__]
trying maybe that guy with the green
lawn maybe he's doing something else I
have no idea but uh
you know
look at me I mean I [__] I fly around
the helicopters who the [__] am I to say
that
um all right here we go is Phil Collins
a good drummer bill
insert generic redhead insult here oh
okay thank you uh what do you think
about Phil Collins as a drummer
his drummer was his drumming was a
staple of the 80s but he never shows up
on any greatest drummers list uh as a
drum Enthusiast yourself can you explain
why is he not a great drummer as an
average music listener but not a drum
expert I think he's he drums like an
awesome [__] but I know [__] all
about the technicalities of drumming
except uh what you share is Phil Collins
great or even good please help Phil
Collins is a [__] monster
he's an unbelievable [__] drummer and
he has his own sound and what I love is
the time when he came up there was this
fad of having no bottom head
on your Toms which are basically the the
you know you have your bass drum your
snare drums and then like you know
basically you know someone doesn't feel
those [__] things those are your
tomtoms right
so there was a time where having no
bottom head for whatever [__] reason
um they were called concert Toms
there was people that just liked that
sound like they went through this whole
studio
uh time in the studio I think where they
were really deadening the sound like
drums are really had a dead sound and
maybe that's why I did it I don't know
I'm getting in over my head very quickly
here but um
he came up you know when he I I go all
the way back to the the when he was just
playing drums in Genesis and Peter
Gabriel was still in it and that whole
prog rock band
um
I think even back then he didn't have
any bottom heads and he he has his own
sound and he's [__] left-handed and
he's an absolute [__] monster
and um in the air tonight that [__]
drum fill that's one of those things
that you know I guess if you play drums
for three months you could mimic it but
could you come up with it
um so why doesn't he get credit well I
would say
because he played when when he played
drums in Genesis they were a progressive
rock band and I think it was I don't
know it was just too [__] avant-garde
it wasn't pop
so
um
he didn't quite get the credit and then
when the 80s came around he kind of
became he became the front man he became
the singer and he'd go back there was a
chest of Thompson and they'd have like
they'd play drums together maybe do a
little drum battle or something like
that but then it was considered oh wow
look he can lose a lot of people even by
the 80s we're like oh he can play drums
too they didn't know that he like
started off as a drummer he's one of
those amazing guys that like
you know is it like Dave Grohl where
he's in [__] Nirvana and your lead
singer dies I mean you usually [__] as
a drummer that guy stepped out to the
Forefront started his own band has
become
a front man in his own right and I
always talk about that I never thought
to think that Phil Collins did the same
thing on Peter Gabriel left
and he just went out right to the front
um Don Henley is another guy but he
always sang when he's with the Eagles
but anyways why doesn't he get the
credit I think because of
songs like sussudio and he was
completely Overexposed in the 80s and he
made really schlocky pop music he went
from being
this underground Outsider guide to just
writing the crosshairs
and being the most successful guy of an
age and then you
you just get branded like you're an 80s
guy and then the next decade comes and
everybody the youth from that
immediately revolts against whatever
happened the previous
[__] decade and then the decade
before is considered cool like in the
80s everybody was about 60 the 60s and
the woods Woodstock was great everybody
hated [__] disco the 90s came around
they were like [__] hair metal and all
that stupid ass [__] [__] and then
all of a sudden the 70s became cool and
the Bee Gees Were Somehow being played
again and [__] uh Dirk Diggler Boogie
Nights all of that [__] Dazed and
Confused all those [__] movies came
out right in the 80s you had like
[__] platoon and all that [__]
talking about the Vietnam War and
[__] Woodstock and hippies and all of
that [__] crap 70s what'd you have
you had Happy Days right Bill we [__]
get it all right
so I think but when you're like uh the
face
of an era
like people won't let you change and
they they uh
I don't think in the 70s when he was
playing drums that they were popular
enough that people understand how great
a [__] drummer he is and um
and then by the 80s he was just singing
that cheesy [__] that I absolutely
[__] hate but DeRosa loves it
and he's like 10 years younger than me
so I don't know but I will say he played
with the he so many [__] great tracks
he played on he played on Robert Plant's
uh I'm in the mood
that that first solo album he did after
uh Zeppelin uh had to break up because
Bonham died I believe it was his first
soul album just [__] amazing drums
for like a pop song and just his
phrasing just the way he chooses
I I don't know just his
the way he expresses himself I I think
he's a [__] monster and he gets extra
cool credit notes because he's a lefty
um I last I read about him he really
[__] up his back as a lot of drummers
did from his era because they knew
nothing about stretching and yoga and
that type of [__] and especially if you
sang and they used to have like those
mics so you'd be playing and you'd have
you'd be turning your neck I know Don
Henley [__] up his neck doing that
um a lot of drummers that sang back then
in fact if you look a lot of older
drummers they go from having a drum
throne to having like that a back like a
literally like a regular chair you know
support their back and um but anyways
I'm [__] rambling here he he's a
[__] monster
absolute [__] monster so uh but what
I heard recently he started playing
again so maybe
fixed his back but uh I read a real
depressing article about a month a few
years ago in Rolling Stone where he was
like retired from drumming and he was
confused as to why he was called the
Antichrist you know because of his [__]
from the 80s and stuff and uh
I don't know I felt bad for the guy so I
was psyched when I heard he was drumming
again so and if I get a chance I'm
definitely going to go see him and I'll
sit through all that sussudio horseshit
just to hear him play drums all right a
[__] up cheating story need advice d
uh dear bill
all right I could really use uh advice
on this I found out accidentally that my
best friend since birth's girlfriend
has been [__] our other best friend
behind his back for over a year now
wait a minute wait a minute let me back
up here I found out at that my best
friend's my best friend since birth's
girlfriend
all right so your buddy since you were a
toddler he has a girlfriend she's been
[__] your other best friend behind
his back for over a year now
oh my God
wow
okay
here we go I was checking something on
his phone and stumbled across naked
pictures she had sent him shocked to see
it I dug further wait a [__] minute
the [__] are you doing with this phone
what were you checking on his phone
wait a minute
what what the [__] this this is this
whole [__] thing is weird
are you the guy that's actually [__]
your best friend's girlfriend and you're
speaking about yourself in the third
person this whole thing is weird
I was checking something on his phone
I've never checked anything on any of my
friends phones ever
you know if they said hand it to me I
look at whatever picture is there and
I'll start swiping around and snooping
you were snooping
what kind of a [__] man Jesus Christ
all right see you snooping on this guy's
phone you stumbled across naked pictures
what do you mean you stumbled across you
kicked on you clicked on the photo app
you scrolled through his photos
she had sent them and then what you sent
them to your phone and jerked off to it
later
I'm probably being too hard on you all
right shocked to see it I dug further
and read the text between them oh Jesus
you were just Fanning yourself weren't
you
um I love how you're just not not
[__] doing anything wrong either
the next thing I was I couldn't believe
it so now I'm looking at his tax record
and his [__] social security number
uh anyways all right shocked to see them
I dug further and read the text between
them saying how much she loves him
and she wished they could [__] all day
and it made me so sick to my stomach
that I went into his tax records uh
sorry she's the nicest girl I ever met
in my life and I look at her as a sister
but now I see how bad she's been
[__] a kid over that's like my
brother with his best friend and I have
no idea what to do he trusts them both
so much that he had no problem with them
going alone together to Green Bay for a
football game
oh my God
oh Jesus they probably [__] on one
type of one of those cheese head things
you know she bent herself over it you
know
goodness
now when I hang out with them from here
on out how could I act normal when I
know what's going on it would destroy my
buddy if I told him if I tell him not
only would I lose the friend I have
wait if I tell him not only would I lose
the friends I have but this girl if this
is a girl he lives with would do
anything would do anything for and is
going to get engaged to her eventually
the four of us are like family family
some stucked in a [__] up position
could use your help here should I tell
him or let it play out no what kind of a
[__] friend are you gonna get married
Maddie geez nah you can't let that
happen this is what you got to do
you got to go out with the other two the
the two dirty ones that are [__]
around you got to sit down and just say
listen I was snooping on your phone I
shouldn't have [__] done it and I saw
the pictures I know what's going on with
the two of you all right
so can you guys please tell him before I
have to
and you have to tell them
you can't just break it off you have to
[__] tell them because you're not
going to break it off you're going to
break it off and you're going to start
[__] again or you lady are going to
go [__] somebody else because you don't
love this guy
just go tell them and break up with them
and get on with your life all right
and just say I'm not judging either one
of you but
you know what the [__] do you want from
me and you had to know that if you're
gonna do something like this eventually
this was gonna something like this was
going to happen so there you go
good luck with that guys I'll be over
here eating a cheeseburger and you just
[__] remove yourself
from it all right
and just to add and I would say listen
man you have you have until the end of
the [__] weekend to tell him or I'm
going to sit him down and tell him
all right that's it and I didn't create
this [__] situation
uh the situation is what the [__] it is
because of your dick and your [__] uh
maybe not in that order maybe in that
order
what are you gonna do and I would just
[__] walk away and uh you know
and I and I wouldn't judge either one of
you guys sound like you're young I have
no idea God knows I made plenty of
[__] mistakes in my life in that area
so what the [__] you gonna do okay they
[__] up
they [__] up and they just got to come
clean and uh he let the [__] fall where
it may
I think what's his face Jim Croce's got
a bunch of songs that your buddy could
listen to
you know
she's living in L.A with my best old
best friend Ray
a guy that she knew that she said she
knew well and sometimes hated
isn't that the way that's what you
should do you should be singing that in
the background when they confess he's in
bed the way they say it goes but let's
forget all that and give me the number
if you can't find it so I can't call
just to tell him I'm fine and the show
I overcome the blow I learned to take it
well I only wish my words could just
convince myself that it just wasn't real
but that's not the way it feels
ah Jesus Christ Bill you're singing the
whole [__] song
um
that's Jim Croce Operator by the way
another sad song
now the sad song by Jim Croce uh my well
here's another one for you here my wife
and I are two months away from the birth
of our first child that's [__]
awesome congratulations I want to hear
your opinion on one of the names we have
been favoring
first name birdie [__] you you're not
naming it kid birdie
you're full of [__] I don't I don't buy
this
I don't buy this at all first name
birdie middle name
Oola u-l-l-a short from my grandmother
Ursula last name starts with a g her
initials would be b-u-g bug is this too
weird of a name
oh you [__] hipster [__] no it isn't
go ahead and name your [__] baby
birdie
you [__] dope I imagine the DMV
calling her name or a teacher calling
her name and roll call what do you think
you know what I think
you don't name a kid birdie
why would you do I don't understand
people who got this did you ever get
this [__] kicked out of you for no
[__] reason
when you were in school
you're literally giving people a reason
every [__] day to [__] with your kid
why would you do that
give her a pretty name
birdie
you know I you know
why God gives someone like you sperm
that works it's just it's just I don't
understand it
I mean you know was I too harsh this
week on people
is birdie is that like you know what I
got to look that up right now I got to
look that [__] thing up right now
you got to be [__] [__] me there's no
way is is that going to be like the new
like Kathy
Birdie the name that's sweeping the
nation
birdie uh that's
that's a golfing term that's what you
hit and badminton
birdie
girl girl name okay let's see the
history of this birdie meaning of the
name
well I remember there was Lady Bird just
Johnson
birdie was until recently a middle-aged
ladies Club
what
birdie was until recently a middle-aged
ladies Club member wearing a bird
decorated hat but now it's just kind of
a vintage nickname think Haiti
is that supposed to be Lucy Josie oh
Josie eyes are going Mammy Millie that's
coming back into style in a big way
actress Busy Phillips named her baby
birdie inspired by First Lady Lady Bird
Johnson as did soap star Maura West
in an earlier Heyday of nicknames
the 1880s birdie was a top 200 name
people who also like birdie also like
Alabama
Alfie Alfred Aspen Blanche
Sicily Clover Dixie Franklin
Hawk
who [__] names a kid hawk
Lenora
Oswald
Oswin
first of all if if celebrities are
naming their baby that it's a good
[__] that's a good one to avoid
oh my God look at these [__] names
Sparrow Remy
Ransom
the [__] name's a kid rants Vesper
win w-i-n
-win God damn it
Zera
to Lucy
t-o-u-l-o-u-s-e Toulouse
I looked at that and with my [__]
dyslexia I just saw a tool shed
patience
who named the [__] kid patience
the [__] irony that I just flipped
out about that
Dixie wait why don't you just call her
truck stop [__]
Frank there's a normal one Franklin
that's all right Gertrude
Jesus Christ what's she banging someone
in the [__] Gestapo Gretel
Cosmo
Guthrie Lottie Maple Marilla
dude these are [__] these are [__]
white people douchebag [__] names
oh my God these fleas are Mortimer
India
heron
haran
that's like how black people say heroin
Heron he's on that Heron you can name it
[__]
a slang for a drug
these these [__] names are horrible
wait a minute let me get this popularity
okay these are the popular names I got
to keep going with this podcast this is
[__] birdie is number 469 on Nameberry
what the [__] is Nameberry
all right it reached its peak this is
like Casey Kasem
the name Bernie reached its peak and
1880 a two ranked at 210.
and then by the 40s wait a minute it was
it dropped all the way down to the
[__] thousand where it belonged
enter a different name all right let's
enter it let me what's the worst [__]
name
I can think of
what's a [__] douchey name a hipster
would not would name their kid
I'm gonna go with lampy
just looked over and saw a lamp
see if that's one
no no lampy is open if you want to be
[__] original
how about fridge
f-r-i-d-g-e it's something a [__]
stupid white person would name their kid
uh we found 21 results
there's no way anybody's naming that kid
fridge
I bet milty how about Milt
Milt popularity
is one thousand percent this week did I
already see Milt I'm just gonna think of
some of the some of the [__] old
singers back in the day
it was Engelberg Humperdinck
about uh Ebenezer
I can't spell this
is there another Z in there
just for the record I'm spelling it
e-b-i-n
-e-a-z-e-r
no [__] results for that oh go [__]
yourself
all right I got it I gotta get one
[__] name that comes out here come on
Ebenezer
ebony
oh that's how you spell it you guys
still listening to this
boy name Ebenezer boy name
all right meaning of Ebenezer
Ebenezer is a name of a Biblical place
the stone set up by Samuel to mark his
victory over the Philistines rather than
a person who was adopted by the British
Puritans as the first name and then
exported to America where it had some
early popularity entering the top 1000
in the 1880s geez I'll tell you 1880s
was a rough time to be born
not only [__] the scurvy and all that
[__] horseshit
he had [__] names like Ebenezer and
birdie
he can just feel their itchy clothes
with those [__] names can't you all
right I can Babble with this [__]
forever all right that's the podcast for
this week everybody go [__] yourselves
uh have a great week and don't name your
kid birdie